buenos días estamos acá actualmente en
uno de los centros electorales más
grandes de la ciudad que queda en el
centro normalmente son filas largas de
gente esperando para ejercer el voto hoy
hay mucho menos se espera o se cree que
es debido a la pandemia y también a que
la oposición ha llamado a un boicot tal
como lo dijiste antes ha llamado a la
abstención ha llamado a que estas
elecciones la gente no venga a votar
porque dicen que son fraudulentas y
porque dicen que no tuvieron las
suficientes garantías digamos esta
oposición mayoritaria para participar
dentro del proceso electoral en una
visita de france 24 por una zona del
este de la capital los centros de
votación ni siquiera tenían votantes
también es muy temprano en la mañana
para saber cómo va a hacer esta
abstención pero los analistas de algunas
encuestas famosas del país señalan que
puede llegar hasta un 60 por ciento el
día de hoy